this is a magic night performance and
I'm just gonna be a little sweating over
there check out the pocketbook stripping
down and braving the pole they may not
be Channing Tatum but they are working
it welcome to the first group date y'all
I think this is the perfect date to get
to know the guys because they don't ever
kind of bare everything and let it all
out there's a lot to kind of tell about
these guys based on today's date well
here's what we know after tagging along
I've ever done here or Craig is kind of
a nervous wreck I wish I had the body to
do it actually and it's either totally
endearing or a total turnoff when I take
my shirt off next to the three dudes I'm
with I'm gonna look like a fatty not the
case for Kody the personal trainer yeah
he's got a ticket to the gun show yeah
this is Magic Cody tonight you don't
know saying
take my shirt off
mark held the salesman is scheming to
snag a rose with his moves my louse will
move I learned it in some movie I walked
back in the day but it goes go something
like this you know I mean I just worked
the hips in there once I find Andy in
the crowd you know hopefully she she
gets it oh she gets it
oh yeah as much as I want that inner
personality let's be honest I'm
definitely looking for these dudes with
their bodies and their shirts off this
male revue benefits The Bachelor gifts
back so it's for charity good job
gentlemen